the lock down in london is easing it
certainly doesn't feel like it
the financial and business district the
heart of the city is usually overcrowded
and bustling
but now it looks like a ghost town even
though the government's plea is to get
people back into the office
i want people to to go back to work as
as
carefully as possible i think it's very
important that people should be
you know going back to work if they can
no although
right after saying that boris johnson
left downing street and set off for
checkers his
country retreat so much for leading by
example
and while the government gave employers
the right to order staff back into the
office
many companies are not rushing into that
decision but
can you blame them when the uk is the
worst hit by the coronavirus
in europe and considering the
government's mantra for months was
strictly to stay at home
stay at home folks stay at home stay at
home
aside for being the country's economic
engine pulling in commuters by the
million
london is also the capital of
entertainment with plenty of things to
do
and places to eat but this 24-hour city
now seems to be in an eternal slumber
it definitely still feels like a bit of
a ghost town compared to
how it has been previously a lot of
people are finding very comfortable
working at home so they don't want to go
back to work in offices
eventually everything will get back to
normal it's just going to take a while
with london still in a partial shutdown
it's expected to have a devastating
impact on the entire economy
if business is scared off by this if the
potential labor force either doesn't
come or goes home
if people don't think london is where
they want to live and hence fail to
attract new businesses
the effect on london's gdp could be a
huge multiple of this
a huge chunk of the workforce at lloyd's
hsbc
and barclays are expected to work from
home until at least september
and google and natwest group are also
allowing employees to work remotely
until
2021 with many other tech companies also
following suit
it's now predicted that in 2021 the new
normal will be about 30 percent of
london-based employees
still working from home on any one day
that would equate to around 178 million
pounds lost on other things like after
work drinks
cups of tea stationery and other office
equipment
each month it's pretty staggering stats
even despite the government's latest eat
out to help out initiative
offering discounts on meals to kickstart
the hospitality sector
this moment is unique we need
to be creative so
to get customers back into restaurants
cafes and pubs
and protect the 1.8 million people
who work in them i can announce today
that for the month of august we will
give everyone in the country
and eat out to help out discount
it offers diners 50 off meals up to a
maximum of 10 pounds per head
courtesy of the taxpayer and it's the
latest of a series of government efforts
to tackle
soaring unemployment but it's unclear
whether or not popular schemes like this
one
will be enough to rescue the economy
especially when the expected second wave
of the coronavirus hits
shout edward stashti rt london
meanwhile employers in the uk are now
required to contribute towards covering
their furloughed workers salaries
such staff are entitled to up to 80
percent of their normal salary but that
doesn't sit well with some employers who
are footing the bill
the owner of the uk's largest plumbing
firm pimlico plumbers says that some of
the staff have been let go for refusing
to return to work
charlie mullins has set out at the
government's furlough scheme claiming
some workers are taking advantage of it
to collect pay without working over half
of workers furloughed during the
lockdown have been returning to work but
millions more have stayed at home
charlie mullins told us his side of the
story
you can look at it how you want to look
at it but i'm just being honest
people need to get back to work and you
know the people that are no longer with
us
are very much the people that don't want
to come back to work and you know
they're the same people that are
spending time on the beach
they're not bothering about social
distancing but their excuse they come up
with
is you know they're not ready to go back
to work but if we were to stop the
80 furlough tomorrow they'll be back the
following day
if you've got a genuine valid reason not
to go to work then
i've got all the time in the world for
them people and of course they need help
you know and we need to look after them
people but the the people
i'm talking about are younger people
people that just
they look basically they don't want to
come to work because they're given 80
of their wages to stay at home it's as
simple as that you know
i'm not just guessing at this i run a
successful business
and unfortunately the system is being
milked
not just by my workers but in general
out there
it's being milked
you